well now it's my turn i think christian
we got the technical stuff worked out
now we're looking at a live picture from
the lee canyon webcam up there and as
you can see looking around we've had
some snow up there
it's been somewhat light so far gusty
winds over 40 miles an hour up through
the spring mountains since early this
morning so it is going to be hazardous
driving and if you don't need to be in
the mountains wouldn't be up there
they are looking at chains required
unless you've got four wheel drive
vehicles so i just wouldn't even chance
it until this system is gone we've had
dark clouds we've had increasingly gusty
winds through the morning hours
temperatures in the mid to upper 50s
right now this is about where we
expected we would settle for daytime
highs today and man those winds have
been picking up speed many neighborhoods
have seen gusts now over 30 miles an
hour mainly out of the south southwest
sometimes southeast but we're looking
for those increasing winds still through
the afternoon kyle canyon near 50 mile
an hour wind gusts nellis air force base
40 plus boulder city at 36 and harry
reid international airport
formerly known as mccarran international
airport has seen gusts over 30 miles an
hour so here's the storm as it's winding
down for northern california it's been
intensifying over southern california
it's got the cold front with it and
around that is snow up in northern
nevada over into northern utah but the
base of the storm is now swinging down
through southern california and central
the san joaquin valley of central
california dropping some pretty heavy
snow in the sierras they'll continue for
the sierra nevada to see heavy snow but
you can see the storm is now starting to
make its way eastward and towards the
desert going to take away the satellite
picture so we're just looking at the
radar right now so we've had off and on
snow up in the mountains since early
this morning and some passing very light
sprinkles now we're starting to see
things hold together a little bit more
where the showers are starting to
actually form and hold together and so
our better chance of rain is coming this
afternoon
and even some heavy rain could be coming
for late this afternoon into the evening
commute and it's going to be a little
tricky especially with these strong
gusty winds we have winter storm
warnings that have been in effect since
four o'clock this morning they'll go
until 4 a.m for tomorrow morning and now
flood watches have been posted for
northwest arizona where we expect to see
the heaviest rains as this system
punches through southern nevada and over
into arizona later today and tonight
we're still looking for maybe up to 12
inches of snow above 8000 feet say at
the ski resort but it's going to have to
drop a lot of snow in a hurry snow
levels down to 5 000 feet and wind
advisories for us that will stay in
effect for the valley and areas of clark
county now until this evening but high
wind warnings those have been elevated
now from a wind advisory to high wind
warnings for eastern and southern clark
county as well as along the colorado
river valley and lake mead so 57 is
about where we are about where we'll
stay and then we'll get these strong
gusty afternoon winds along with rain
showers developing and sometimes at
times those can be heavy tonight we'll
look for evening showers then things
will start winding down partly cloudy
skies temperatures are going to be
chilly in the morning into the 30s
tomorrow a few clouds and sunshine and
low 50s for the rest of the week and
mornings dropping to near freezing again
christian as we head towards the weekend
all right sherry thank you so much i'm
going to